Stage 4 lung cancer that the testicized to my brain was resolved after three chemo
Abuminal treatments by recent
Brain MRI and chest PET scan this week confirms no cancer
The ecologist is leading toward moving me to just the ketruda without any more chemo because my white blood cell code is low
Yeah, the ketruda typically
Will not lower your white blood cell code. It's the chemo. That's doing that
Do you have any maintenance protocol that I should supplement with the ketruda every three weeks?
Well, I can't remember what I have you on
But I will tell you that there is a current study going on right now at Mayo
With people that are on
Abuminal therapy and it's a study adding
The aloevia immune product
so
The doctor the
Medical researcher doctor. She it's a female who is
Who is doing the study with Mayo
Really believes that the aloevia immune is the best coupling
Nutrient for immunotherapy
And the results are going to be another five years probably but
That's just an interesting thing. It's going on
So if you're not taking the aloevia immune then that would be something to think about